Avengers infinity war released some very
interesting photos to Entertainment
Weekly as part of an in-depth feature
for the film the article and photos are
full of big reveals about this movie's
story and characters so let's take a
look at these photos and break down all
the details you need to know and yes
boiler warning in case you don't want to
know anything about infinity war be
honest guys you're worried about okay
let's take a look at this first photo
it shows Stannis on the ruins of that
planet that we've seen in the in the
past trailers now we've speculated that
this could be Xander but now Marvel
Studios confirm that this is the ruins
at Thanos his homeworld Titan Titan is
one of the moons of Saturn it's where
Thanos was born to a race of eternals
before becoming an outcast becoming
obsessed with war and death now in this
movie it sounds like nanos is bitter
from Titan getting devastated by war and
he sees himself as a savior to the good
half of the universe aiming to destroy
the threatening and imperialist half and
I'm guessing earth is in the bad half
now look more closely at this image it
looks like Danis is using the Infinity
Gauntlet to clutch this big moon and
this guy behind him Kevin Feige
confirmed this in a quote that they
announced is grabbing the moon guys
we're gonna see Thanos Chuck a moon an
Iron Man like spike in a football he's
it's use Grogg let's move on to another
photo here showing Rhodey joy named cap
and black widow Rhodey notices wearing
some techie leg braces that allow him to
stand upright following his injury in
Captain America Civil War speaking of
which is interesting to see these heroes
on the same side again considering yeah
they were definitely recently beating
the piss out of each other at that
Airport in Germany now accordingly their
article all of these heroes end up in
Wakanda in an effort to protect vision
cap decides to move him there because
really yeah let's be honest is the best
defended location on earth it's never
been invaded most people know about it
and the article also says that Thor and
rocket are in Wakanda as well with
Mercury a new version of his hammer a
battle axe that we now know the name of
Stormbreaker now these new photos also
include new looks at duck strange dark
long and banner and solo shots of cherie
and Loki but the third one I want to
look at is this great shot of Peter
Parker's in the side of his school bus
in the trailer we saw him on his school
bus looking out at the window I'm
assuming this is part of that scene at
first I was wondering if Peter like
climbed out
as the bus was driving up to go swing
away in action to investigate that cue
ship but looking closely look at the
bottom it kind of looks like I'm
wondering if the bus is even on asphalt
there doesn't look like she flying or
floating yeah somebody's throwing a bus
off a bridge that gave out I don't know
lastly we got to talk about the
magazine's cover there was a teen
difference one of them teacher Tony
Stark's new Iron Man armor upgrade this
new design is for appendages emerging
from his back Wow okay now it's now
confirmed that this new armor is being
referred to as bleeding edge we've been
speculating about this for a while and
the recent promo we actually saw his
armor weaving over his neck and shoulder
is it similar to the bleeding edge in
the comics action in the comics that
emerges from it so much those were
things that first reminding me of the
the Waldos of the iron spider armor the
glasses like four appendages actually
these are confirmed as rocket boosters
by maybe he's propelling himself through
space maybe that's how he ends up on
Titan well let us know what you think
about this new Stark armor and thanasis
moon toss and the general epic scale of
this movie I'm curious to hear what you
guys think in the comments below and a
reminder to subscribe to new rock stars
for more updates and alice's adventures
infinity war an all marble movie
coverage thanks everybody